the creative process within the
marketing world is being challenged and
it's being challenged because there are
tools and methodologies now that involve
the consumer in the development and
review of the creative process more than
ever before the marketing companies that
are doing things well are the marketing
companies that are bringing the consumer
in early on to test and learn about how
people will react to a particular
message to understand what they would
want in product development so when the
product actually launches the consumer
has already been involved with the
evolution of that product so if you
think about starbucks again my Starbucks
has been a great boon for them where
people are helping to design new drinks
for them and their harnessing the power
of the consumer to bring their ideas
into what will be potentially the new
drink for them there are automobile
companies that are enlisting the help of
the general public to help to design the
car of the future what do they want the
car to the future to look like what
attributes do they see it as important
and those features are being fed into
the product design element and the
developers that are them being inputted
into the cars which ultimately you now
have a virtual focus group to help you
in your marketing message and your
design process